at that point it had gone to her brain
and I didn't realize how quickly it was
going to be from there and we had sat
down and had a conversation and she was
telling me about how she might have a
lot less time than what we had
originally thought
[Music]
and the first thing I said was well will
you be there when I graduate college
that was six years from the time in
which we were talking and I remember she
was like no that's that's not like and I
could see that I wasn't getting it what
was weird is when he was sick I almost
wouldn't I tried not to see him much
because I was like you're fine and it
wasn't until like the very and that you
know I was like oh my goodness like what
did I you know that was my period of
denial but I didn't want to stay the
truth out loud and so I kept coming back
to her with some other points like what
about at high school graduation at this
time I think I was a sophomore and she
had said no and then it began to hit and
I feel like even at fifteen like I still
really wasn't grasping there's nothing
that she wouldn't do for us including
holding on for you know eight years of
being in pain with breast cancer and you
know metastasize to other parts of her
body and weird things happen but she
just held on because she didn't want to
leave us she had breast cancer and it
kind of came up pretty sudden for us and
then just over the years it got better
it got worse I got better got worse and
then eventually just a few months of
that just getting terrible I remember I
said to her what about my birthday which
was in October and we were in June
talking and she said that she wasn't
sure and what had happened was she wound
up passing away two weeks before my 16th
birthday eight years is a long time for
to not know if someone's gonna be alive
whether you're here to get home from
school I kind of ignored all the signs I
knew she was sick she was in the
hospital for a handful of months maybe
like four or five months and then she
got out of the hospital and she came
home
and it was wonderful to have her back
home and then something just happened
and she went right back into the
hospital further than about a month
after that and at the end of that month
she did pass away the night before he
passed he was at the hospital and he sat
down and gave me some words of wisdom
about life almost like he knew and
almost like I knew and we didn't say
much and I went home and I remember you
know when when I got a call at 5:18 and
it was really and then I knew there were
moments in time and I remember in the
beginning of my journey where I kind of
gave into being dark and gave into being
depressed and almost was like I know I
felt like the way that I handled it was
like I know the depression is coming I
know the anger is coming so I'm gonna
take control of it what I thought was
taking control of it and make it worse I
did feel very sad and obvious I just
lost somebody very important to me and
it kind of manifested itself into this
selfish nature where the little kid in
me was like why me why did my mom have
to die it didn't make any sense I often
wish I could just ask my mom for advice
on regular everyday things relationships
emotions I wish my mom could be by dog
yeah just life I wish I could ask my mom
about life when when we lost my dad
recognizing that my sisters and my mom
we all grieve at a different pace and I
think what's interesting about loss is
it makes all of us like really
vulnerable the person who's lost the
people who are trying to support the
person that lost something vulnerable
and I think if we don't come at it with
a lot of grace for each other like
relationships could go back I wish that
I had spoken up sooner she said
something to literally anyone I can't
count the countless hours in which I
spent alone because I chose to do so and
I didn't have to now I'll have casual
conversations and I'll be like oh my
gosh my mom and I used to do that all
the time and it will be so second nature
because I'm healing and because I like
talking about her and because I like
sharing I do talk to my mom still very
openly we have an open dialogue every
night before bed kind of therapeutically
I go through my day because when she was
alive all she wanted to hear about was
my day and so it's kind of a way for me
to reflect on my life as well as still
kind of have that connection that we had
when she was alive
you